[Musique]
cette présence a dérangé beaucoup de
monde parce que qui ne trouve pas il se
trouve pas normal que le fait que la
ministre il est ministre qui avait un
autre ministre à côté elle s'est mise à
jour
c'est pas l'homme qui prend la mer voilà
donc lui il est ministre de la mer voilà
donc c'est important la mer s'il y a des
fois il y a des bateaux tout ça
c'est important et cette pression ça
dérangeait beaucoup d'internautes qui ne
trouvent pas normal le fait que les
ministres se permettent de s'amuser
alors que le pays est dans la tombe
surtout ce soir là où en fait et a été a
été promulgué la loi pour la retraite
oui mais tout est choquant dans cette
image déjà si c'était pas du tout un
concert populaire c'était un petit
événement quasiment privé alors les
places étaient en vente le fait qu'elle
s'affiche avec Rihanna Pharrell Williams
et sa pro qui on dirait qu'elle fait
partie du rap game non mais bon on
dirait qu'elle va sortir sa mixtape et
elle se prend pour une on va dire on va
dire que c'est franchement c'est
maladroit et surtout le timing et
désastreuses
et il faut dire qu'elle aurait quand
même pu y aller parce que les places
étaient payantes elle aurait dû payer
140 balles comme tout le monde elle est
dans la fosse
comme une histoire est privé
les ministres de la Culture sont
toujours invités dans les événements
culturels c'est un événement culturels
c'était pour la Fondation c'était privé
certes pour l'exposition
ce soir là c'était la décision du
Conseil constitutionnel qui touche tous
les Français les Français tu vas pas
faire la fête je suis désolé
bravo Bernard
parce que c'est à la Fondation Louis
Vuitton c'est pratiquement en même temps
que le le c'est les Sud rails Sud rails
qui avait envahi le siège de LVMH en
fait voilà donc c'est l'image du luxe
elle y va le elle à la rigueur on
pourrait se dire c'est professionnel
mais le ministre de la mer qui s'éclate
il doit jamais s'éclater sur du rap il
va faire moi je prends ça limite comme
une histoire
on cherche la justification
là franchement
heureusement que nous avons la famille
Arnaud alors là
simplement
du fils de Bernard Arnault c'est l'image
du luxe ça va pas du tout ce soir là
c'est elle qui déconne il faut les soirs
et qui veulent qui fout là-bas il y a le
ministre de la mer après le pauvre voilà
il était voilà il était
souvent la nouvelle vague
dans n'importe quel démocratie sauf la
France visiblement il se passe ça la
ministre le lendemain n'est plus
ministre c'est impossible pensez aux
États-Unis au démocratie du nord de
l'Europe qui est le plus ministre et
c'est impossible ce déhancher alors que
le Conseil constitutionnel une loi
valide une loi alors que la France est
dans la rue qui a des manifs que c'est
extrêmement compliqué mais c'est quoi ça
justement démocratie mais c'est mauvais
timing ça démon mais non mais elle n'a
aucun sens politique de faire ça en plus
donc ça démonte qu'elle n'a absolument
pas sa place comme ministre quand on
secrétaire d'État à la mer c'est indigne
qu'est-ce qu'il foutait là
allô ça va il arrête ça va il a pas
énormément de taf en plus parler de lui
la fin il a échoué dans cette soirée
moi je suis jalouse parce que j'aurais
adoré y être mais je suis pas ministre
donc pour moi c'est digne de deux
gugusses si tu respectais ton peuple
déjà tu allais si tu voulais vraiment y
aller parce que tu adores cette musique
et que c'est ta passion soit mais tu
restes dans les coulisses tu te tu te
fais discrète tu tu respectes les gens
là elle savait pertinemment que de toute
façon qu'elle soit aussi de Rihanna ou
pas elle allait être filmée à cet
endroit là parce que c'est le c'est le
quartier VIP on aurait su qu'elle y
était donc ça veut dire qu'elle s'en
fiche complètement de savoir que que les
gens savent où elle est et moi je trouve
ça naze vraiment toi qui est toi qui la
voix de de la sagesse
pour moi c'est juste mon ami comme ils
ont comme a dit tout le monde c'est le
timing qui dérange c'est c'est que tu
peux pas dire aux gens vous allez
travailler deux ans de plus ils ont pour
ceux qui se rendent pas compte de la
souffrance que de certains Français qui
font souffrir les Français par leur
réforme par leur loi nécessaire ou pas
nécessaire je suis contre cette réforme
mais c'est pas étonnant mais je vois pas
qu'est-ce qu'elle est partie faire
là-bas pour pour aller danser en VIP
au-dessus de Rihanna le message est
catastrophique c'est vraiment je vous
insulte et je m'en fous même si on passe
le soir même une réforme qui va faire
travailler des gens deux ans de plus qui
pourront peut-être même pas aller
jusqu'à 60 moi je m'en fous j'ai mon
mojito j'ai mes cocktails et je danse
j'en ai rien à de ce qui se passe
en France c'est le timing qui me dérange
moi après elle est pas ministre du
Travail ministre de la mer il est pas le
ministre du Travail elle a la ministre
de la Culture elle a le droit d'y aller
c'est une question de timing moi j'ai
l'impression quand je la vois j'ai
l'impression qu'elle m'insulte qui me
dit je t'emmerde avec tes deux ans
elle a dit j'ai entendu non mais c'est
bien la danse mais c'est le timing c'est
des trucs de VIP comme ça j'aime pas
c'est pas bon après la voix de la
sagesse la voix de la décadence
il y avait rien de populaire là-dedans
c'est un truc de privilégié de Bobo elle
s'est fait un kiffe parce qu'elle
voulait aller dans une petite soirée
avec plein de stars et Fianet et cetera
bah c'est pour défendre la vraie culture
parce que culture c'est un mot très
large voilà quand il fait le droit
de Bolloré
Valérie Valérie Valérie parlez vous
parlez que de symboles et de
communication la politique
du gouvernement
je la connais pas moi
je trouve que une ministre de la culture
dans un lieu de culture Samsung
pardon alors effectivement histoire de
timing mais il y aura toujours il y aura
toujours un décret il y aura toujours
une loi il y aura toujours un problème
donc voilà tous les jours
travaillés deux ans de plus ce n'est pas
la ministre du Travail c'est la ministre
là en l'occurrence vous faites le en
fait vous faites le jeu enfin vous avez
été endoctriné en quelque sorte par
toute l'opposition que ce soit la droite
comme la gauche d'ailleurs c'est
engouffré dans le truc en se disant oh
mon dieu c'est génial il y a une micro
polémique qu'on va monter moi
je regarde juste une image de quelqu'un
qui est membre du gouvernement le soir
où on passe une réforme pour la retraite
qui est en train de se déplacer son
travail
de la culture
qui galèrent et qui vont qui qui
galèrent pour gagner de l'argent on l'a
jamais vu ça
c'est la Fondation
des ministres à quoi qu'il le voit
exprès ils sont jamais dans le monde ils
sont jamais dans le bon symbole non tu
me disais tu as raison
[Applaudissements]
la publication des symboles il devrait
faire un peu attention aux gens je suis
désolé si j'ai tourné le reste parce que
effectivement c'est un événement privé
voilà madame
j'aimerais
qu'on voit ce qu'on pense c'était les
spectateurs voilà tiens voilà alors
j'attends et bah voilà voilà
catastrophique avec vous
si tu avais des notes comme ça tu aurais
dit que c'était catastrophique ma belle
je te dis bah pour moi c'est catastrophe
pas que c'est une excellente ministre de
la culture comme la souligné
qu'est-ce qu'elle a fait comme il est
dans la culture produit escalier génial
il y a pas de bêtises tu as vu ce
qu'elle nous fout dans la gueule
en fait ah mais c'est vrai non mais en
fait tu es bête excuse-moi artiste au
palais Tokyo ça c'est très bien
je sais pas moi j'ai pas son numéro
comme tu as tapé comme je suis derrière
pour t'avoir toujours
il a besoin d'avoir encore une serviette
voilà avec les minions
qui vous adore voilà non mais c'est vrai
je suis sûr en chef allez merci